within minutes of the breakup
announcement the split news took an
interesting turn wild speculation about
a brad pitt jennifer aniston reunion
social media went crazy one fan tweeted
quote somewhere Jennifer Aniston is
crafting her hey let's grab coffee and
catch up text a brad pitt check out this
Brad Jen post called quote make America
great again and these fun gifts Brad
finding out about the split Jen
considering a reunion and our favorite
Brad Pitt when he finds out Jen Aniston
is single so is it possible are Brad and
Jen reuniting well here's what we've
learned a source tells et that they are
quote absolutely not together however as
the source put it you can't protect the
future according to the source Aniston
and Pitt have stayed in touch since
their split they have each other's cell
phone numbers and communicate from time
to time adding quote this is nothing new
Jen and Brad have remained friendly the
it couple married in 2000 and divorced
five years later as Brad started to date
Angelina Jolie when we're not with the
kids we yeah we tend to just go to bed
they filed for divorce in 2016 a source
tells us Brad has been dating but only
casually also keep in mind Brad still
isn't officially divorced from Angelina
a source told et that quote there's a
pause in the divorce process because
they both made children the priority but
nothing significant has changed in their
relationship
[Music]